LEADERS.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
"ANGLE"
"ANGLE."
TODAY, WE SAW A STARK CONTRAST
PLAY OUT BEFORE OUR EYES IN REAL
TIME.
THE CONTRAST OF TWO LEADERS.
NANCY PELOSI AND DONALD TRUMP.
NOW, PELOSI IS A LEADER IN TITLE
ONLY.
YEAH, SHE IS THE SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE, BUT I THINK I'M RIGHT,
LAST SPRING SHE SAID IMPEACHMENT
SHOULD ONLY BE BIPARTISAN.
THE SAME SPEAKER WHO COULDN'T
GET ONE REPUBLICAN TO JOIN HER
LYNCH MOB.
BUT THAT DIDN'T STOP HER TODAY
FROM MILKING THE CONVEYANCE OF
THE ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT FOR
ALL IT WAS WORTH.
>> THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES
IMPEACH THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
IN IMPEACHMENT THAT WILL LAST
FOREVER.
THIS IS A VERY SERIOUS MATTER,
AND WE TAKE IT TO HEART.
IN A REALLY SOLEMN WAY.
>> Laura: IMPEACHMENT.
OH, THAT IS WHY SHE WAS WEARING
PEACH.
I COULDN'T FIGURE THE COLOR OUT
TODAY.
IT WAS A DAY OF CHOREOGRAPHED
MOMENTS THAT WERE SUPPOSED TO
INDICATE THE SERIOUSNESS, THE
PRAYERFULNESS OF ALL OF THIS.
NOT POLITICAL, AT ALL, OF
COURSE.
IT ONLY UNDERSCORED THE
VACUOUSNESS OF PELOSI AND HER
COLLABORATORS.
>> WE ARE HERE TODAY TO CROSS A
VERY IMPORTANT THRESHOLD IN
AMERICAN HISTORY.
TODAY, WE WILL MAKE HISTORY.
A THRESHOLD IN HISTORY.
AS WE MAKE HISTORY THAT WE ARE
MAKING PROGRESS FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> Laura: PUT IT IN THE
SMITHSONIAN.
HOW IS A SHAM IMPEACHMENT WITH
ZERO CONVINCING CHARGES AT ALL
MAKING PROGRESS WITH THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE?
IT'S NOT.
THERE IS ONE PERSON MAKING
PROGRESS FOR THE RECORD PEOPLE
TODAY.
IT WAS DONALD TRUMP.
WHILE NANCY WAS TRYING TO PASS
HERSELF OFF AS A SECOND BETSY
ROSS, TRUMP WAS SIGNED IN PHASE
ONE OF A TRADE PACT WITH CHINA
THAT WILL DIRECTLY BENEFIT YOU,
THE AMERICAN WORKERS, AND OUR
INDUSTRY.
THIS IS A DEAL NO ONE THOUGHT
WAS GOING TO HAPPEN, BUT A
TACKLES INTELLECT OR PROPERTY
THEFT, ENFORCEMENT TRIGGERS, AND
KEEPS TARIFFS IN PLACE TO KEEP
THE CHINESE HONEST.
>> WE ARE GOING TO WORK TOGETHER
FOR THE BENEFIT OUR COUNTRIES,
BUT ALSO VERY IMPORTANTLY, FOR
THE BENEFIT OF THE WORLD.
SO THIS IS A VERY BIG DAY FOR
THE UNITED STATES.
>> Laura: SORRY,
MR. PRESIDENT, BUT PELOSI WAS
NOT GOING TO BE BESTED BY SOME
HISTORIC TRADE DEAL.
NO, SHE HAD HER OWN SIGNING
CEREMONY OF THE ARTICLES OF
IMPEACHMENT.
PLATTERS OF HORS D'OEUVRES THAT
WERE, I GUESS, BROUGHT OUT TO
COMMEMORATE THE OCCASION.
WHICH SHE CLUMSILY USED TO
CREATE HER SIGNATURE.
>> IT'S A FUNNY SIGNATURE.
BUT THEY DO GIVE A LOT OF PENS.
>> Laura: SO SOLEMN.
ALL OF THE COCONSPIRATORS WERE
GIVEN A BOOBY PRIZE.
MAXINE WATERS LOOK LIKE SHE WAS
WAITING FOR THE ROLLING STONES
TO SHOW UP.
IS NOT A MAGIC WAND, AUNTIE
MAXINE.
I CAN'T GET THROUGH THIS.
BUT DON'T WORRY, NANCY QUICKLY
RESTORED ORDER WITH THE
APPROPRIATE SOLEMNITY.
>> WHEN THEY BRING THIS OVER, IT
WILL SET IN MOTION A PROCESS ON
THE SENATE SIDE THAT WILL TAKE A
SPECIAL OATH OF OFFICE TO DO
IMPARTIAL JUDGES, AND DO
IMPARTIAL JUSTICE, ACCORDING TO
THE CONSTITUTION AND THE LAWS.
>> Laura: JUSTICE, JUDGES.
IT HAPPENS TO THE BEST OF US,
ESPECIALLY LATE AT NIGHT.
THIS IS A TOTAL JOKE.
NEXT CAME A SOLEMN PROCESSION OF
THE ARTICLES TO THE UPPER
CHAMBER.
WHAT LOOKS LIKE A PARADE OF
FOOLS GETTING THEIR STEPS IN FOR
THE DAY.
THE ONLY THING THE PARADE LACKED
WAS NANCY IN THE LEAD, CARRYING
THE PATRIOTIC INCENSE, OR MAY BE
TWIRLING A BATON.
YEARS FROM NOW, WHEN WE LOOK
BACK ON THIS DAY, NO ONE IS
GOING TO REMEMBER NANCY'S CHEAP
THEATRICS.
THEY WILL REMEMBER, THOUGH, HOW
PRESIDENT TRUMP BROUGHT THE
CHINESE TO THE BARGAINING TABLE
AND DELIVERED ACHIEVEMENTS IF
YOU EVER THOUGHT WERE POSSIBLE.
HIM THIS IS WHAT REAL LEADERSHIP